I mean you obviously
um you're I was gonna say like you are
very uh in terms of your your ceiling I
feel like it's like super stardom
because of your personality would you
ever considered acting doing movies [ __ ]
like that nah most definitely I ain't go
a lot like when the time is right when
it makes sense but I'm definitely gonna
do what I like I'm just waiting for the
opportunity hell yeah that'd be crazy
without a TV show or some [ __ ] I I own
TV show for me be sending girls backs
it'll go viral like I have my own shoes
yo what is the one skit you've done that
you got the most backlash about
um or negative feedback or people like
yo what the [ __ ] are you doing because
you've had some wild skits he played the
news the whole channel is like I feel
like oh you got the bootleg coming over
just slide that thing back there you go
it's right on yeah so now I feel like
the whole challenge because you got some
people that I haven't seen this so what
is it yeah it's called the Horse
challenge well I'm sitting on girls
backs because I don't got a permit or a
license so when I sit on a girl back and
still Transportation wait wait sir and
she like she like travels for you so
she's like your horse she's my horse for
me so now it's the horseback challenge
but I feel like that's that's something
that people gotta understand you for me
because you know you guys that's that's
my kind of humor
maybe for the wrong reasons but I'm with
it yeah it is for me that's why it's
like for me it's however you look at it
but how much you weigh like a buck buck
50 Buck 55 171
68 I go along
probably right now I don't know I
definitely gotta check the horseback
challenge yeah I'm getting on any girl
back and she would let me I love that a
lot of girls got strong backs that I
mean yeah are you are you single at this
point in time Ron
um
I'm not gonna say I'm single I'm having
fun you're having fun I'm having fun
that's important I'm young you are young
[ __ ] I have fun I don't gotta settle